校長の教育論とあと人間論を理解して
もらうために全体像からまず動物行動学
っていうのが土台にあってでその上に
仏教授事教があってで大和魂っていうこの
順番でお話ししていこうかなと思ってるん
です
けど動物行動学はね割と新しい精神論有名
な人はローレンツというこれノーベル小学
者やね動物工学でノーベル賞取っただけど
も彼が動物構造学を発表したのはかなり
年取ってからない。もっと早くやっとって
くれればよかったんやけどね。ダーウイン
と一緒でね、ダーウインが進化論を出した
のはもう死んでもええと思った頃ない。と
いうのはダーウィンの進化論も動物行動学
も反キキリスト教ない。だから下手すると
魔女裁判にかけられてヒアフりされちまう
。だからもう死んでもええていう時まで
できんのや。発表できんのや。もう完全に
こいつを解明し尽くした。
だからもう新度もええという風にして発表するんや。向こうの学者というのはそれぐらいの覚悟をしてやるんやで。
[音楽]
これどういう学問なんですかね?
精神論なんだけどもそれまではキリスト教から来る精神論やったわけやね。つまり想像論。神が人間を作った。で、その時に神は人間だけに理性を与えた。
だから理性が正しいんだというのが基本に
なっとるわけで、ここが1番大きな間違い
なんよね。理性は自分が作るもんであって
ね、神に与えられたもんじゃないんよ。神
が人間に理性を与えたからだから看んぼに
も理性があるって言い出したい。だけど
あいつら喋らんし行動しないしそこの
大きな間違いをそのまんまほったらかし
て論を進めていったもんであいうわけの
わからん哲学とかになっちまうわけやね。
理性が正しいんだったら哲学は正しいなら
理性論もんね。完全に
動物行動学論の学問なんですか?
動物構造学今までの心理学精神論やね。
それに対するアンチとしてできたんや。
心理学というのは最初哲学の中にあったん
やねから理性が正しいという前提に立たん
と心理学はできんわな。だけどもそれの
血管が色々出てきてフロイトが出てで
フロイトがアメリカ行って成功したんかな
。あれ精神分析をやってもらってだけど
本当のところをいくらやったって何の効果
もないっていうのがだんだん分かってくる
わけやね。で、その頃もう効果がないと
いうことを分かった頃に日本で投稿拒否が
大問題になってきて、それもフロイトで
治るんだと言い出して、ヨットスクール
なんか行くのは精神分析で直してやる。
全然治らんよ。当然のことないだってね。
考えてこら。あの頃投校拒否のことを情緒
障害時って呼んどったんだ。情緒というの
は本能のランクにおける感情のことだ。
それが障害されている。すなわち能が狂っ
とるという意味やないか。そいつを理性で
直すカウンセリングっていうのは理性で
直そうということやから本能には理性は
届かない。そうやね。理性で本能動かす
ことはできない。できない。だから元々
フロイトで直すとかカウンセリングで直す
とかありえないことなんや。この頃言わん
やないか。絶対治らんからで、そこに我々
が逮捕されちまって、そしたらやっぱり
色々言ってくる人がおって、オタクのあれ
は動物行動額じゃないですかということを
言ってきた人がおって、手紙が来てね、
立派呼んでみようと思って呼んでみたんや
。そしたらまさにそうやん。動物高度学と
いうのはね、本能論なんだ
。
動物行動学と校長の出会いっていうのは一旦放置で教育がストップした時に他の支援者の方が教えてくれたみたいな感じ。
うん。あの日本の裁判っていうのは非民主義だからマスコミが言ったやつは、え、逮捕された後本当は
日目で交せないかんのよ。総せと自由入行動と裁判戦えんじゃん。情報も集めないかんし。
ところが日本はね、公師書の中に放り込め
て新しい証拠を集めさせんのや。そしたら
あの検察が負けるといかんからね。で、
そういう非民主的なことをやるんやけどね
。そんな風になることは分かっとったもん
でまず23年は無理やなと思って。だっ
たらその23年もったいないもんで。これ
は1つ今までのあれをまとめてやろう思っ
てね。で、何を元にしてまとめる、何かを
基準にしてまとめるんやから、そん時に
動物行動額どうでしょうって言ってきたの
がおるんや。テレビなんかで理性が間違っ
とる本能が正しいということを言うもんで
、それを聞いとった人が本能論だったら
これだということで動物行動学を進めてき
たのだ。うちはまだ動物行動学知らんやっ
たからね。それでやってみたらうん。この
通りよということや。本能が全である。
動物行動学はそういうことやで。から
あの知書生活は無駄やなかった。自分の
やってることをまとめるにはね
、動物行動学の中にな、こういうことが
書いてあるんよ。私の言ってるローレンツ
やな。ローレンツが言ってることは東洋で
は昔から言われてたことなんだと。仏教な
んだからローレンツが言ったことは彼は
19世紀20世紀の人間やけど紀限全5
世紀2500年前にすでにお釈迦様とか
講師がいるとったことないだからキリスト
教が悪かった一心教だから他のものは一切
認めないという態度を取るもんで全ていい
ことは全て神のせい悪いことは全部悪魔の
せい簡単に切っちまうもんでね後でが困る
ことになるわねそれが動物工作学本能論。
ついでに攻撃という題名。理性的には攻撃
は悪くと言われとるけども本能的には善な
んだぞという。何しろ本能だから自然なん
や。自然は善なんだ。だから本能から来る
攻撃これは善なんやから特にその主内攻撃
これは善であるぞというそういう本能で
それから様々な本能を解き明かしていくん
やね。
で、あれから見るとタイマスって内攻撃じゃん。だからある目的を持った全内だからそいつをいくら言ってもう罰は開くということでこり固まった連中には通与せんのや。
他の動物も罰んですか?
他の動物だってお犬が噛み合っとったり大きくなっても出ていかん犬を母犬が噛みついて追い出したりしとるじゃん。あれが攻撃や。主内攻撃。
主攻撃は全であるということがまず分から
んとそのためにあるんやでと。本能。本能
というのは善なる目的を持って本能がある
んや。だから理性ができたのはいつ頃か
知らんけどもずっと本能的に人間も暮らし
とったわけやろ。滅びなかったじゃん。
どんどんどんどん反映してったよね。から
本能の目的は種族保存だから種族保存に
合うように出来上がっとるから主内攻撃だ
。主作保存のためにやっとるんや。
包丁の精神論の定義だと、ま、精神が行動のプログラムでその中に本能と理性があるっていうお話だと思うんですけど、この世の中のわゆる心理学はこの理性による精神論しか扱ってないってことですか?
理性しかわからんのや。ま、授況はね、誰かが作った本能論を学問として残したるわけやね。仏教は自分で別れという自分の本能。
それが仏教なんやけどな、いずれにしても
本能が正しいということが分かった上で
やっとるわけ。完璧な人間。これ仏教だと
如来。授教だとね成人だと思っとるけど
本当はね人
って言うんよ。真の人誠の人って書いて
新人って思うんや。これが如来と一緒で
これには自分がトレーニングしてそうなる
。ここが仏教も受教も宗教じゃない理由だ
。宗教は神がいる。神がいないと宗教は
成り立たないで。それを仏教なんかあれは
単なる教えだから教え儲からんのや。学校
と一緒やね。宗教は儲かるんだ。だから後
の人が儲きために宗教にしたんやね。で、
今それが残っとって本当の教えの部分は
あの仏教なんか残ってないよね。
能論を学びたいってなった時に帰るのが動物行動学と授教と仏教ってんです。
だから動物行動学はそれを具体的に分かるように説明しとるからね。自分の本能を見つけるとこまではちょっとあれ無理よね。その方法は書いてない。
番ええのはやっぱり仏教やね。仏教は自分の本能が分かるようになっとるよね。
最後に動物行動学で包丁が実際に読まれた本とか学者におすめの本とかあったりしますか?え、
番最初はソロモンの指輪。これもローレンツやけどな。それを読んでから攻撃。これを読むといえばいいなり攻撃はね、なんかこうちょっといや、この役でええんかなと思うようなとこもあったりしてな。すっきりせんだけどモンの指輪を最初に呼んどくとなるほど。
こういうことやというのがようわかる。
入門書なんよね。だから入門書から呼んで
きけええよ。あれは呼んだ方がええよ。
自分が分かる。
う。